[Music]
from Colin Trevorrow until someone saw
the book of Henry and the director who's
never seen a landing
he couldn't not stick comes the epic
conclusion to the force awakens Star
Wars Episode seven point five the rise
of Skywalker I got a bad feeling about
this the last Jedi asked you to forget
everything you knew about Star Wars so
when some fans threw the kind of fit
usually reserved for ethics in games
journalism Disney panicked and tried to
match the pieces back together in this
hollowed-out shell of a trilogy that's
missing any consistency in its plot
themes or characters unless you fill in
the blanks on Twitter read all the
novels and happen to be running some
fort night squads with the boys during
the crossover event the day of victory
is at hand the day of revenge the day of
the Sith
oh that's what the dead speak was
referencing for tonight
just like how Return of the Jedi
revealed the second test or in root beer
tapper
when we left them the resistance was
down to its last gasp and the first
order reigned supreme
now stuff has happened and the
resistance is back to fighting strength
while the first order is taking loans
from the rich old Grampa they don't call
anymore they'll strike a dark bargain
with the only character left on the
rotting carcass of the original trilogy
Palpatine or a clone of them
that's like rotting away and Snoke is
also a clone and he's being pickled I
don't know not super clear the emperor
is enacting the same plan he had last
time troll a young Jedi into striking
him down strike me down and up journey
towards the dark side will be complete
strike me down and my spirit will pass
him to you and when that fails hit him
with the old zap hands but luckily the
same Luke Skywalker who bailed in this
whole mess also left a scavenger hunt to
stop him sending our heroes running to
find the thingy has been inscribed upon
that leads to the other thingy that
leads to the bad guy she's going to exit
oh she's showing us how to get there
well the first order keep sending them
running whenever some character growth
is about to happen there's an incoming
destroy you gotta go now you know I've
been thinking a lot about this film and
the biggest issue it has at its core is
oh no TIE fighters everybody's grabbed
all the new characters you still barely
know after three movies have returned
like Poe who I guess was a smuggler at
some point your friend's old job was
running spice completing his arm from
Han Solo type to just Han Solo Finn
who's still fighting against all odds to
keep himself in the movie I need to go
alone we go together we're all in this
got to go after her
Maz Kanata who snatched a metal out of
Laius cold dead hands just a place in 40
year old pan boys these poor Schmucks
whose stories must have been cut for
time kylo Ren continuing the Skywalker
tradition of being a genocidal death
cultist who's redeemed by a single act
of good and ray who's taken Luke's
x-wing his lightsaber his book
collection possibly his childhood home
and his last name
Rey Rey Skywalker huh was replaying the
long game cuz I think Luke just got
talented mrs. Ridley don't like the
newcomers don't worry no one is ever
really gone rejoin your old pals
Threepio Chewie Luke Leia Han and Lando
who are so sidelined at this point that
one of them has fake memory wiped remedy
restoration complete one of them faked
eyes one of them thinks last Jedi was
for fake fans only China his weapon
deserves more respect one of them dies
from causing the fake death of her son
one of them died two movies ago and is
so over this franchise he wouldn't even
get a haircut to cameo as a memory and
one of them is alive and well enough to
seemingly hit on his own daughter well
that's fun though didn't know that's who
Jana was supposed to be it was in the
rise of Skywalker visual companion book
idiot he should have been reading that
in between rounds of fortnight you call
yourself a Star Wars fan so strap in for
a conclusion that brings so much new to
the franchise from the new force powers
they would have really come in handy for
qui-gon jinn
- hammering it home that all these dead
stormtroopers were actually kidnap
children harvest more of a galaxy's
young to finally see the Knights of red
do absolutely nothing than go out like a
bunch of weak-ass punks and mercifully
brings the new Star Wars cinematic era
to a close with a sloppily constructed
hastily executed mess that managed to do
the impossible
unite fans who loved the last Jedi and
fans who hated the last Jedi by pleasing
none of them
starring Oh we're using our made-up
names then I'm Rey Skywalker Huck Finn
narco pollo gentle Ben used the force me
the only consistent character across all
nine films participation trophies don't
force so hard you'll end up just like
your brother an old man wearing the same
outfit he had in his twenties cut off my
man the rocket here rolling James Dio
Tony said cloned this in a cave bland
moff tarkin a rose by any other name
would get to speak how can I be a
mechanic I have no arms
Darth sibelius you know what's cooler
than one Captain phasma six captain
phasma's and rays dramatic reveal phase
[Music]
[Applause]
star wars episode 9 the last Star Wars
for a while at least they really need to
think this through you know I'm starting
to think it's a bad idea for one studio
to make every big movie engineered to be
a douchebag but you do the toys what you
do to the Falcon Falcons a lot better
shape in here ZB I smell on fire what's
left of them is it on fire on you left
[Applause]
[Music]
wash your hands
I've got a lovely bunch of coconuts
there they are all standing in a row who
you calling a cootie Queen you lent
liquor I'm sorry for peeing during be a
man